es un pionero fue una de las primeras
personas en Francia que apostó por la
biometanización un Proceso biológico de
degradación de la materia orgánica que
permite generar gas
el metanizador copia del funcionamiento
del sistema digestivo de las vacas
reconstruimos el proceso artificialmente
en los tanques desde hace 10 años
recolecta los residuos agrícolas y
agroalimentarios para producir biogás a
partir de estos un gas de la misma
calidad que el gas natural que es
inyectado en la red de distribución
maurice genera 13 gigavatios hora al año
suficiente para abastecer a varios
centenares de hogares de la zona
es muy importante logramos producir la
energía verde para abastecer el
territorio y a Escala Nacional podemos
imaginar que en 2030 los agricultores y
otros actores del sector biometano
podrán producir el 20% de las
necesidades energéticas de Francia lo
que significa que si hacemos bien el
trabajo no necesitaremos el gas para
mauritz hay otra ventaja utiliza los
residuos de la fermentación llamados
digestato como fertilizante para sus
tierras este digestato conserva el 100%
de sus valores agronómicos lo que
significa que yo como agricultor podrá
utilizar este producto que aunque no es
orgánico si es muy natural Comparado con
el abono químico que solía utilizar y
comprar Así que tiene dos ventajas la
primera es menos contaminación y la
segunda es mucha menos dependencia de
las fluctuaciones del precio de los
abonos químicos que están directamente
relacionados con los precios de la
energía que se han disparado en los
últimos meses
Aunque organizaciones como
reconocen las ventajas del biogás
advierten sobre nuevas prácticas que
podrían repercutir en los precios y la
disponibilidad de las materias primas
lo que no queremos ver es que los
agricultores empiecen a utilizar
pesticidas abonos sintéticos y arriesgar
cultivos intermedios solo para
recolectar residuos para abastecer los
metanizadores Ah
el objetivo de la agricultura es ante
todo producir alimentos
los agricultores franceses pronto podrán
contar con otros recursos abundante la
recolección de los residuos alimentarios
será obligatoria a partir de 2024 el
sistema ha sido puesto en marcha en
varios municipios de la región Parisina
desde hace algunos años personas como
lestex distribuyen pequeños botes de
basura marrones para incentivar la
separación de los residuos acá puede
tirar todos los residuos de alimentos
también puede tirar las cáscaras de
huevo El yogurt no el tarro sino lo de
adentro huesos espinas puede echar
cualquier cosa que sea comida y las
cáscaras de las papas Exacto todas las
cáscaras como el compostaje
cuando me levanto por la mañana sé que
estoy haciendo algo bueno lo estoy
haciendo por una buena causa una causa
que me importa mucho el medio ambiente
me duele ver basura en el suelo o que no
todo el mundo recicla que todo el mundo
conduce un auto
y me digo que estoy haciendo algo que
ayudará a cambiar las cosas estos
residuos eran tratados en la futura
planta de mecanización al noreste de
París el centro de tratamiento de
residuos domésticos espera cubrir la
demanda de gas de 5,000 hogares y
suficiente digestado para que los
agricultores de la región puedan
fertilizar dos mil hectáreas de tierra
la cadena alimentaria desde la
producción hasta el consumo incluidos
los residuos representa el 15% de las
emisiones mundiales de gases de efecto
invernadero
así que ocuparse de esta parte de
nuestros residuos
también significa reducir nuestro
impacto sobre el cambio climático
el sector de biometanización actualmente
produce 8,5 teravatios hora es decir que
un reactor nuclear Francia espera
duplicar su producción de aquí a 2025